the jurogan experience and in another
case
i saw it was a magpie one of these birds
known for how smart it is
there is a full uh uh
you know half liter um
you know plastic uh thing of water it
was just water
okay you know a water bottle and it was
full
so the magpie goes over and sips out the
water
now you can ol the beak is only what an
inch and a half long or an inch at most
so
it goes in until it can't reach the
water anymore so what does it do
it goes off to the side gets a rock just
the right size
drops it into the water bottle
it raises the level thereby displacing
water here it is
that is you've got the there it is and
so
it comes and it goes back and gets
another stone
drops it in and every time it drops it
in the water level rises and it can
drink more water and it just it keeps
doing this
that's pretty amazing okay and so
so every time we study animals
they're smarter than we ever thought
they were
so maybe for our own ego we kept
building ourselves up
saying how separate and distinct we are
as humans in the animal kingdom
when maybe we're not as separate and
distinct as we
think we are so now
what's my broader point there about that
i was making i
just distracted something about ufos
yeah i know i'm just trying to get back
to ufos on that the
the fact that we have high resolution
cameras in our pocket we take videos of
things that are very unusual
so exactly so here's video of a magpie
doing
bernoulli experiments on a on a on a
water in a water bottle
who would have known that even happened
right right okay you can't
bring the bird into a lab and and then
maybe you could but i don't know that
anyone did all right here's my point
um in the 1960s and 70s there were many
many reports of alien abductions
people said the aliens came to me and
they brought me in and then they
released me
do you have any footage no they took my
camera or no
they zapped my my film and now there's
no image on the film but there were
countless stories well now you can
stream
live from your camera
anything that's going on in front of you
so if the aliens come and they want them
duck you stream it
that would be instantly viral
oh my gosh you know the stuff that goes
viral
is much less than that a cat that a
kitten that jumps to the table and falls
that goes viral you don't think of video
footage of an alien is not going to go
viral
instantly but there's none
so i'm just saying i'm thinking if we
were being visited
somebody would have some good footage if
we were being visited
i'm thinking maybe google satellite
images would catch
spaceships that are not airplanes moving
on our surface
if we were being visited i i'm thinking
we'd have something better than fuzzy
monochromatic
video of of of objects that apparently
reveal themselves only to navy pilots
right so one of the reasons is most of
these sightings actually occur
far offshore in the ocean and the
speculation is this is
one of the ways no obviously i'm gonna
put my tin foil hat on nice and tight do
your thing this is one of the ways that
they monitor us the best way to do it is
to do it
where they're hold their base where no
one is around which is the ocean
no that's not true they go in the ocean
they pop up and they fly that's not true
what do you mean it's not true it's not
true
yeah nobody lives on the ocean yes
that's correct but have
lives down under siege this is what the
speculation okay
that's why these trans-medium devices
have been okay
these trans medium crafts have been
observed if you want
if you are sure we are being visited by
aliens and you don't
actually have really good evidence then
you have to say that
sure well you know that you have to say
that you have to say
this is really happening and they're
observing us and they're concealing
themselves in this particular way
you have to say that so that's the
that's sort of
that's your way to maintain your your
your alien belief system by saying that
and i don't have a problem with it go
get him
go get him but all of what has been put
forth as
evidence for aliens to me is
insufficient evidence to excite my
interest
my research interest in devoting time to
finding it out
but it definitely has excited other
people i have not stopped them
i am not saying defund the military
uh program on uaps which of course is
just
updated ufo i know they like to say that
now because it's like a stigma too
i know that's just that that's a really
transparent
sneaky way no no it's not even sneaky
it's actually i think it's embarrassing
it's like maybe if we call them uaps
people take them seriously
no i'm of the belief that they're
probably akin to what we did on mars
i don't think there's aliens in them i
have a feeling that these things are
probes
and i feel like if you just think about
biological entities flying through the
universe like why do that
right when you have sophisticated
technology that's good enough
right now from our like relatively
primitive in
consideration of what we think is
possible a million years from now right
but we can send that mars rover around
we have a helicopter
on mars i mean there's multiple
satellites flying through the universe
right now
taking images we we can do all that yeah
but now our
probes are not targeting
the martian military fighter because
there's no martian military
but if there were we certainly wouldn't
hang out in the open right but if we had
something like
are you familiar with um one of the most
famous cases
was a case with uh commander david
fravor
of the navy who uh encountered with
one or two other jets off of the nimitz
they encountered this thing
that was shaped like a tic tac you know
everybody knows this yeah this story
it went from they tracked it going from
80 000 feet above sea level to 50
in less than a second they have no idea
how it moved there's no visible
propulsion system
it was blocking their radar it was
actively blocking tracking this is what
their
sensors yes told them exactly just be
clear about that and then
you're stating information as though it
is
fact i'm stating information as
commander for i don't care
that doesn't matter he's human right and
we're all human here but
as a scientist when you're presenting
information you don't say this thing was
at 80 000 feet and it
dropped to zero to sea level in one
second or whatever it was the the
measure
that's that's the wrong way to report it
what you say is we have
sensors that told us
this is what happened i understand what
you're saying okay yeah that's a very
important
distinction yes and so
so now all right
your first question then tell me about
the sensors yeah okay
or are they double checked are they you
know that and
so so but if you're just gonna say
there's this
craft at 80 000 then you everyone is
thinking about
a craft and no one is thinking about the
sensor
they actually saw with their eyes too
this is something that they actually
you can't see something at 80 000 feet
no the the the actual
visual on the crowd okay they didn't see
it at 80 000 feet but this craft
it's not just something that was tracked
with equipment got it but they didn't
see it at 80 000 feet
that's my point so so uh by the way this
level of that of that of of attention
i'm giving to the detail and the
reporting of information
we do that with fellow scientists
for much less oh for sure than
if we're being visited by intelligent
aliens from another planet
go visit a go go to a scientific
conference and watch the level of
scrutiny we put
on other people's work if they have a
sensor that has a new result we'll say
did you calibrate the sensor
did you how long has the sensor been in
use what
uh a given example here's an example
okay um do you remember planet x
yes the search for planet x nibiru
uh that was one uh there was sorry there
were several
incarnations of planet x right that was
among them
okay that was i'm talking i'm talking
about a hundred years ago planet x
okay thanks a few hundred years ago well
there's several planet x's right so
um uranus was moving weirdly nobody
understood
maybe there's a planet beyond it whose
gravity we have yet to
reckon in our equations up boom we
discover neptune
wait a minute neptune is moving a little
a little uh unfamiliarly
this is why my phone is sorry about it
you're gonna drop that thing and break
it with no casing
so yeah this i got the 12
and yeah i can still do this i'm just
sorry yeah i get it last time you were
here you had a broken case
you're a broken back remember
so uh why are you distracting me
i was like on a roll and neptune
neptune so so neptune we're looking at
neptune's orbit
and it's not following newton's laws
and this is odd well we've been down
that road before
uranus didn't follow unions laws we
proposed another planet and we found it
so neptune's not following all the laws
of gravity that from all the other
planets in the sun
there must be another planet out there a
planet x let's look for it
is that bodes law bulesi is a is a
fitting function that gets you it
it got a little more attention than it
deserved it's just that planets
um every next planet is about twice as
far away from the sun as the previous
one
so you just make a quick equation out of
that and that's but it doesn't work for
mercury and it
didn't work for pluto and i thought it
was based on the mass of the planet no
not at all
and mass has nothing to do with it and
it predicted the asteroid belt but the
estrogen belt there's no planet there
right okay and if you add if you glue
together all the pieces of the asteroid
belt
you get something like five percent the
mass of the moon
so yeah it gave us the location of the
astro belt but that's not
a planet so bode's law it's fun to play
with but
you know there are limits to how far you
want to uh declare
its relevance to the actual universe so
we're out here at neptune and so it's as
i said maybe there's a planet x
everybody started looking
everybody started looking including
percival lowell all right
back in the 1920s and he said i want to
find planet x
because something's perturbing neptune
so he sets out looking for it
and he doesn't find it then he hires
clyde tombaugh
and he dies so he doesn't see the
results of this clyde tombaugh
said i can't find it either i will just
systematically search everywhere
because if you think something's
affecting you gravitationally you ought
to
have some idea where it is to be tugging
on you
in that way right that's not that's not
some kind of weird
it's it's like you're moving differently
where must the thing be to tug on you so
that you're moving in that way
no one could find such a planet x so
clyde
tombow said it's got to be out there
somewhere i will systematically
image the entire sky all right you got
to do it on multiple nights
because if something's moving you'd see
it change from one picture to the next
he does this discovers pluto was pluto
where planet x was supposed to have been
no
was pluto the mass that planet x should
have been everyone assumed it was
but over the decades the mass of pluto
got lower and lower and lower as our
estimates got more and more accurate
then we found out that pluto is is
one-fifth the mass of our moon
made of half ice and this is why pluto
got into trouble
later in the in the 20th century it's
not it's not because we had some
vendetta against pluto pluto just never
belonged in that list to begin with
that's really how you need to think
about it anyhow
there's still the matter of neptune's
orbit pluto did not have enough mass to
make
those changes so the search for planet x
continued
so what happens all right
uh 1993
a colleague of mine named miles standish
okay
he's probably related to the mile
standish on the mayflower
he is an astrophysicist looked at all of
the data people were using to say
neptune's orbit was crooked
looked at all the data then he found out
that at one particular observatory
was it the gearbox or the timing
mechanism
had just been cleaned or swapped out
or there was some because in the
observing log you write down everything
because you just don't know okay was
there a glitch in the current
was there a bird fly over you make notes
of everything
one of the observatories whose data was
being grafted together with the other
observatories
had this sort of gearbox but i don't
remember it was a gearbox there was some
mechanical adjustment that was made
he said i wonder if that had an effect
on the positioning of this telescope he
removed
those data from his analysis
and fitted data to all the other
telescopes that he had for the positions
of uranus
of neptune when he did that
planet x evaporated in that instant
in that instant there was no planet x
all the other data
when it connects across removing the
data from the one where the
observing log said they did something
different
uh uh neptune fell right on to newton's
laws
and so so since 1993 there is no planet
x
and pluto and and we're it not for that
we probably would have been a long time
before we discovered pluto because no
one would have looked for it
they found another like let me just
finish the lab the lesson there
okay the lesson there is
you have information that you think is
correct from your sensors
this was an observatory a fine
observatory
and you're gonna say this observatory
says neptune
is misbehaving but then you learned
there was something wrong with the data
you throw it out so
uh so i'm just i'm trying to say this
happens all the time in science
you have to be careful what you're
analyzing
before you declare that what the thing
measured is true and then
realign all your resources to address
what you think is true
when it might have just simply been a
glitch or multiple glitches or anything
and we do this all the time in science
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience